man about New York that's what Hans Kim
[Applause]
what's up gangsters gonna be here -
honks can I
I am Asian
we're gonna be pressing X I am Asian was
another century of Chinese and from a
province in china called south korea
renessa japan province beautiful there a
lot of people make fun of agents because
we dogs which I understand can be very
shocking because in America dogs are
treated like family members but in Asia
we treat our family members like family
members
this is where a little tradition we have
where instead of buying an animal we
love our grandma unless she's a baby
girl in which case we throw out the room
rules are rules
lob it is a hard day dozen Asian man
everyone thinks Asian women are
beautiful not everyone thinks Asian men
are beautiful which doesn't even make
any sense because how do you think Asian
women are created I mean you know
everyone's try not to [ __ ] me but I'm a
crucial part of the sexy process okay if
you have sex with me our children will
be very beautiful
half of them another half will be great
engineers and I'll support you
I love dating
I used to date a beautiful lady who was
related to yoga and choke sex and I was
like do you enjoy breathing or not we
got your mind out there I am single
right now I have yet to meet my soul
mate I'm beginning to think maybe it's
her fault she needs to get out for seems
like a loser I think I can do better I
got a lot of dating advice for my
friends like dude you know learn how to
talk to women maybe or maybe women
should learn how to listen to Hans why
don't you want to hear about the Federal
Reserve so interesting what a party come
on
I do the ladies I don't think I can ever
have sex with the dude sorry fellas I've
I'm straight as [ __ ] I've never looked
at a beautiful woman and been like wow
she's gorgeous but is there a version of
her that's bigger and hairier and it's
less Highness
and throw that in my old caboose I I was
talking to this homophobic dude who's
like dude we're so lucky we're not gay
can you imagine if most of the gender we
were attracted to wasn't attracted to us
back I was like what man can't even
imagine they must quite constantly those
other people those people yes love
talking to ladies you know how I was
having this one girl she was like did
you know that my vagina is a 3d printer
this I can make a baby like that is not
accurate your womb is a 3d printer your
vagina in the train not even a very good
3d printer Libra is one thing with lots
of errors it's nine months to print it
the whole time is printing is
complaining do not any trig is that nice
I am uh you know I'm a dude
and I think ladies are ladies and I
respect them you know because I feel
like if a dude trying to give burden we
would not be as good as the ladies okay
ever dude trying to give birth you like
bro I've been eating so much protein and
creatine during my pregnancy this baby's
like 27 pounds already bro check in a
six-pack in the ultrasound
don't let this gain to the first
trimester not healthy stop car bloody
look at the baby I am NOT homophobic you
know I think it's funny when people will
say it Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve
because Adam and Eve were not even a
good couple biblically first of all they
raised first of all they disobeyed God
and they ate a fruit they weren't
supposed to eat which is kind of gay and
then the rains came in Abel and can't
murder table what are you thinking
parenting advice from people who raised
a murderer they're only three other
people on earth because a quarter of the
world's population got the whole earth
you could just move to kill your brother
you psycho
startup we're relying on you have the
genetic diversity I am NOT a Christian
now I used to be a Christian
I grew up agent as a Christian person
which is kind of weird because the
people with the Bible didn't even seem
to know that ages existed you could have
a job this align in Asia and scratch off
all the fireworks really proud of you
guys keep it up
we love you nothing this is all Jews
there was one line I have an atheist now
because I'm not in kindergarten I have
an internet connection
I think it'd be stressful to have a
worldview that could be destroyed by
facts like walking down the street oh
look also there goes my Tuesday think
about this all day pretty awesome that's
pretty cool I am Asian as I said you
know I love to eat General Tso's chicken
and my Asian friends make fun of me and
they're like Hans is it General Tso's
chicken a shitty Americanized version of
something authentically Asian
I'm like yeah that's so money
my favorite memories rush hour 3 I'm not
a racist
I hate people too I just get to know
that first you meet people for their
skin I hate people for their souls don't
make it to my level
I didn't have a moment of racism once I
was on a plane and I saw a dude reading
a book in Arabic which kind of freaked
me out but then I saw it pulled the
corner of the page and put the book away
and I was like oh thank god he's got
future plans oh yeah blow themselves up
in the middle of a story on a racist I
also am a big fan of the Black Panther
movie I thought that movie was great
because it gave black children a hero
they could finally look up to and not
just someone like Martin Luther King jr.
of Malcolm X or Harriet Tom and Rosa
Parks they're good morrow show off her
dick that was Michael Jordan jay-z Tupac
biggie
Vietnam during Washington Carver another
is a big person that dress like a cat
this gel is really going to come out the
yellow panda I
I have a very pro immigrant I mean look
at me I've got wresting immigrant face I
don't understand these people who are
like you know who's taking all my money
these people with less money than me
I've got my money what about the people
with the money maybe they took your
money
[Laughter]
I think capitalism is great if you want
to do it but don't make everyone play
your stupid game
I like fortnight I don't make your
grandma play and take away our house if
she lose this surprise I got seven head
shots when you're baking cookies I am
NOT a communist okay stop calling me
that
Eretz but they do support any policies
that Republicans consider communism
ashes whenever two or more people
gathered to do something nice
I find it hypocritical when Americans
will be like communism never works as if
we didn't spend billions of dollars and
kill millions of people to make sure it
wouldn't work
remember Vietnam there's a pretty
anxious about it not working
communism never works because whenever
people control the means of production
their democratically elected leaders
mysteriously died small rubber group
always finds the automatic weapons look
they're hitting themselves they look
stupid but not a communist just put a
bow on that not a Congress love America
you know patriotism Boston we're here
this might be the wrong town for that
joke love patriotism but I do think that
it's not the best thing all the time you
know I don't think everyone is patriotic
is stupid but I do think everyone who's
stupid is gonna be a little patriotic
because they're you got nothing good
going on in your life you're gonna be
like well wait some here this is the
best year here I love rednecks you know
rednecks are cool because they could
survive in any wilderness situation that
you put them in except a situation where
everyone has equal rights I kind of
[ __ ] them up a little bit you can
survive I'm gonna swap with an alligator
why can you survive in that cul-de-sac
with a minority
pick it out I'm smiling over here I I
think it's funny that there's a lot of
things here like don't drop the soap in
prison I think that's a funny saying
because it's not even helpful I should
be don't pick up the soap we could drop
as myself as you want depending over
where they really get you if you don't
drop the soap you're so gonna get raped
I'm just gonna really clean hands all
that happens I think there's a taxon of
it you guys will just have to google
that later I won one last joke you know
I think it's fine that Tanner's a white
person say you know tell me what should
be like hey there's my Mexican friend
Tanner that's not black montañas all
right
[Music]
[Applause]